we're dealing with political leaders who
are will be gathering at the UN on
Tuesday who are not treating the climate
crisis with any sense of alarm or
urgency you know we hear these warnings
from scientists you know they're
becoming increasingly panicked and our
politicians sort of pay lip service to
how concerned they are about climate
change on the one hand but on the other
hand it's basically drill baby drill I
mean they're opening up all kinds of new
frontiers for fracking for tar sands for
coal and so people in the streets are
going to be expressing their sense of
urgency what we're hearing from the UN
is that it's great news that there are
all of these fortune 500 CEOs that are
going to be gathered there including
from some of the the largest polluting
corporations in the world and the idea
is that they're going to voluntarily set
targets and and and fix this for us and
that I think is a really dangerous idea
the real clash is between that extreme
ideology and what we need to do to
respond to this crisis because of course
we need huge public investments to roll
out renewable energy and also to protect
our cities and towns from the impacts of
heavy weather that's already upon us
these systems are incompatible and the
rules of one system can be changed our
economic system but the rules of nature
can't be changed
well I think there really is a new wave
of climate activism of climate justice
activism and that's I think that's what
I'm I'm most excited about in terms of
the what's going to be happening on the
streets of New York in the coming days
we're really going to be seeing a new
wave of climate activists who know who
their enemy is they're not under any
illusion that they're going to convince
you know shell or BP out of the goodness
of their hearts to abandon their core
business model which is to dig up ever
more fossil fuels I think that that
model of environmentalism that has
really dominated in the u.s. since the
80s which is this partnership based
approach which isn't asking polluters to
pay for the crisis that they created but
rather is looking for the polluters to
sort of play to come up with the
solution themselves on a voluntary basis
that models just discredited so I guess
if I have any advice it would be know
your enemy or you're gonna be supplanted
by this new way of of environmental
activism one more download the agent
plus mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now